from from at this point you have to have
faith that there you have to have hope
that a Republican sweep of the house in
the Senate plus a trump victory will
reverse course and save this ship and it
doesn't matter if you think it can't
either
even if you think like I was saying
maybe we've already lost that's not I'm
not saying we don't go vote we don't
keep trying
it means like maybe we need to start
making plans for what that that entails
so tell me what would that entail what
does that mean if they want a lot of
sins that's it just moving out of cities
yeah that's that's and then we we take
it one step at a time okay so you have
people who have been indoctrinated their
entire lives and are a part of a new
religion that cannot be broken from
their minds and we have four years of
Trump hopefully if he wins - - I
shouldn't say Trump something about
Trump it's about the Republicans doing
230 reform section 230 reform would be
like a silver bullet that will you know
reverse course so fast for the online
community for this country yeah
forcing these tech companies to uphold
legal speech will flip this boat around
in two seconds the DOJ has already
proposed it it's a good idea it's a good
night they can't get it through the
house and so it's not gonna happen
unless the Republicans win both the
House and the Senate that is our best
hope well they don't want that because
that that is like their last vestige of
control you know the the fact that they
can ban anyone that disagrees with them
that they're canceling people left and
right that are further on the right than
what they want you know I'm I'm proud
I'm probably on their radar right now
they they do I'm sure I'm on their lip
many canceled yeah kind of your video
where you're explaining voting for Trump
they new loop to that several times yeah
I'm pretty sure Facebook shadow bands my
my post now because yeah dude I've been
very vocal on Facebook lately so when
when people know that I'm I'm not happy
with it
when Tim Poole does a video where he's
like cancel culture is bad but you know
Trump Trump is still kind of bad - they
say that's fine ignore him yeah but then
you jump on the show and you're like no
I'm going I'm going all in for Trump
yeah then they're like that
problem you know they tolerate me they
want me to be as far right as people are
willing to go then you step on board and
you're like I'm going all in and they're
like bad news video on a puddle shut it
at me man I heard nothing I will never I
won't change I won't change my vision my
opinions because they want me to no way
I'll stand against that wall man as
Terry said tonight I would die on that
wall died on that hill yep
gladly I'll stand with Terry Crews man
so what do you do if the blue wave hits
they sweep the house of the Senate Biden
wins and it's just blue all across the
board baby now Mike Serna [ __ ] said in
this scenario it would result in a very
far-right government in four years
because Joe Biden is weak and the blue
wave would result in a loss of law and
order people in cities and rural areas
would not tolerate the lawlessness and
it would cause a major backlash among
the silent majority who rushes out you
know and then votes in all hard right
across the board based on the trajectory
of British politics there's good reason
to believe that regardless of the polls
we are going to see the biggest
Republican victory in a hundred years in
in but that makes sense but it's not
based off of a hard data point it's
anecdotal
yeah but the youth the hard the hard
data points that they're shoving down
everyone's throat we've already known
that they're they're not not the truth
they've been broken for since 2015
probably was poll that problems probably
before him but it didn't matter because
they had their mascot as president when
Obama was in the presidency for eight
years polls were relatively you know
pointless right so the polls could have
been broken for two decades now good
point and we might not even know yeah
absolutely right I can't track it
properly I wasn't political back then I
had no idea
but the important the important thing is
that the national polls in 2016 weren't
actually wrong they got the the popular
vote mostly correct
there was a margin of error so they
actually got it right because the
problem was that the probability of
Trump winning was was considered to be
nil however what
what's that pole called nor nor path or
whatever oh that was a professor who is
professor yeah he's saying 91% chance
that Trump wins yeah off of primary
votes you want uh something crazy New
Jersey won't release the primary
locality for drama no way yeah really so
the official reporting is that the
numbers will not be counted as the race
is on component so maybe that's the hope
maybe maybe maybe they're desperately
trying to sweep this under the rug dude
they're trying to convince the public
that there's no hope anymore I see it
when I look at you
talking to me for the past 25 minutes
I'm not saying don't vote and don't
fight I know that that I know that
that's not what you're saying but you
are awfully defeated about this and
that's what that's I'm not necessarily
you might not be convinced but that's
what they're trying to do they're trying
to convince people that it's pointless
you've lost don't even you can't speak
up or cuz we're gonna cancel you we're
gonna call your job I'm saying to speak
up I am to the point I'm making I'm
speaking up the point I'm making about
recognizing we may have already lost is
that even with four years of Trump and
the Republicans the culture of the far
left will not change and these people
are indoctrinated they will not be
changed see I don't I don't know if I
agree with that because of what we were
talking about last night about how you
know how how fast we've gone in six
months right how fast have we got here
how long has it changed and then you
made a good point of you know we really
haven't looked at the nuances of how
long it's really been going on which is
more like since 2010 2012 bye-bye yes
since the abundance of everybody being
on Facebook and becoming like a younger
and younger children you know kids have
gotten onto Facebook at an earlier
earlier age what you know what is the
the number one thing Chinese kids want
to do when they grow up do you know what
the answer is an astronaut astronaut
yeah that's right American kids you know
what it is youtuber influencer they want
to be influencers they might have I told
you how this started know what so I'll
give you I'll give you the the academic
breakdown I had a conversation with
Peter Berg ocean about this we did a
podcast and James Lindsey and Helen
pluck rose and his view as a you know
he's in academia
he's an associate I believe he's an
associate professor of philosophy was
that it started this mentality this
ideology of intersectional ISM started
in the late 70s 80s and they started
teaching people the stuff eventually the
professor's had this ideology and
started teaching their students and it
spread since then ok and now we have a
generation that were raised on this
ideology they've entered the real world
ok so well I want to lose the reason I
was bringing this up so so we got here
and we're here now right everyone's seen
it everyone because it even because of
the pandemic it's even more crazy
everyone's actually seeing it talking
about it I'm saying wow this is really
crazy this kind of mentality that people
are gaining because of the internet
we're calling out teachers we're seeing
what they're actually teaching our
children people are starting to
home-school so so it took us to here and
I think it's going to be even faster
when we we suddenly just go we've had
enough I already reform we need it I
absolutely grew to 30 reform would be
Donald Trump pulling out of what was
that gun we were watching earlier the
500 Magnum Magnum 500 Magnum the barrel
was super long putting a silver bullet
inch boom President President Trump if
you argue listening to me right now or
our show number one I'd be honored
and number two listen to what he just
said he would be pulling out like you're
see the joker when the joker pulls it
that really long row yeah I love that's
putting a silver bullet do yep two
things 230 reform and ending the war on
drugs oh definitely if true wall I mean
if Trump came out and said like the week
before the first thing I'll do is an
executive order releasing nonviolent
offenders amazing yeah I think it's I
think it's sitting in his pocket I think
I think he's sitting on it maybe I hope
so I I don't know why he wouldn't do it
it's so weird to me it's like I mean
maybe there's something we don't know
about what's going on in the inner
workings of government but here's oh let
me tell you why 230 reform is so
important so go back to that point about
how we got here when I was bringing up
Peter Burke ocean that was his view and
I disagreed many different ideologies
exist many different non theistic
religions exist and they're not
prominent intersectional ism became
prominent because of
Facebook algorithms when Facebook
launched and publishers realized they
could make money by getting shares on
their articles they started creating
clickbait quick I think I think
clickbait was invented by upworthy the
so the specific clickbait people don't
understand this clickbait is when you
omit information from a title so that
people feel pain emotions it no you feel
a pain another emotion I I guess it's
actually a negative emotion physical
painful response emotion
so when you see a headline that says I
can't believe this man actually did this
to the dog how gross sure well no what
happens is you there's actually a
negative physiological response people
have when they don't experience the
complete process that makes them want to
like I have to know I have to have the
complete pull through right you have to
tell me what it is
mm-hm and so they realized this and
started repackaging content videos
YouTube videos but clickbait titles
which generated a ton of revenue so
here's the basic process a publisher
emerges and goes on Facebook and they
write a news story they say Adam Craig
ler lands perfect backflip people see
the headline and they're like or you
could have said hardflip perfect hard
flip because I actually did it was
fantastic yeah
Adam quick learn nails hard flip in the
backyard you could say that a million
times I just know now what if they did a
clickbait headline I can't believe Adam
curricular pulled this off which one
gets more traffic the second the
clickbait obviously yeah they started to
realize that anger actually got more
shares than clickbait that's true and
Rueben and and so the evolution changed
and and that women share more than men
so they realized that when they would do
a video or an article about police
brutality they would get ten times the
shares of an average article and so
immediately the boss this company said
do more of this all of a sudden you were
met with with this this conundrum we're
a legitimate news organization would get
a thousand views and your clickbait rage
the police are bad would get five
thousand five hundred thousand yeah five
hundred amount yeah
then the venture capital came in and
they said who do we fund well clearly
they get way more views fund them you
know something magical happened
the people realized that if they wrote
about racist police they would get X
views they also realized that when they
wrote about sexist police they would get
Y views Oh ding lightbulb racist sexist
police is X Y views X plus y views or
arguably X times y and that's where
intersectional ism became extremely
prominent you ended up with articles
that would say something like there's
there's one article from vice that was
like black trans women fighting police
brutality are the are you know are the
feminist heroes we need for black lives
matter it's like they just took
literally every word possible and jammed
it article we read about Ivanka Trump
exactly yes that put all of the key word
yeah or like that that that little video
that's how vice makes their Venezuela
the transgender is telling dealers and
then that's an actual article well so
but that's that's true yeah and so you
were getting these different keywords
that would attract people but then vice
also learned the lesson yeah just put
racist sexist anti-gay Donald Trump and
now but now we're at a phase where all
those certain generation of people you
know including myself like there's a
certain age group that that kind of fell
into that right and they were they were
a part of that and now we're kind of
coming out of it and a lot of those
people have kids a lot of my friends
have kids they're teaching their kids
that this is craziness
you know they they're aren't letting
them have iPads anymore yeah it's kind
of like I feel like it's coming around
you know I I'm I can only really speak
for myself ever so in my own personal
experience I'm seeing what they're doing
I'm I know what clickbait is the word
the term clickbait is in everybody's
vocabulary we all know what clickbait is
we don't really the definition of
clickbait is has changed okay well again
my own personal experience and the
people that I know every almost every
person I know you knew what clickbait is
yeah I'm pretty sure you know I'll do it
I'll do a a poll you know a this ninety
nine percent of people right now say
clickbait is
like a sensational title that's not
clickbait okay
that's either like you could argue it's
rage bait range may do something
different you know clickbait literally
is so there's a there's a for my reddit
called saved you a click that
specifically targets clickbait yeah
people now refer to rage betas clickbait
okay rage bait would be like you know
racist sexist to anti-gay donald trump
does a backflip and can you want people
to get angry so they click on it yeah i
would argue that it's the same click
click bait is a literal definition well
we can rename you lady can talk
semantics but i i don't want to you can
argue that rage debate is a form of
click bait from a parent tree kind of
perspective sure but the or is just gota
the origins was literally omitting
information to trick someone into like
to force them to click yeah but I think
one thing they happen with that too is
if people got tired of it I just started
scrolling past and I'm like if you don't
tell me I don't want it absolutely
you're absolutely right yeah and I think
that's why it's Brent section 230 reform
I love that I think it's a good a good
idea and we need we need that the DOJ
proposed it there I don't think they go
hard enough the general idea is that if
the speech is legal it can't be removed
otherwise you'll lose your liability
protection but they're making speech
illegal anyway it's like they're they're
choosing what's legal so like what
where's the line they're clearly not
caring anymore they're like whatever
we're just gonna ban whatever we don't
like so you're saying we lost its
helpless no absolutely not we have to
stand up more than ever yeah so we'll
speak up there's a CLE what I'm saying
what there's a challenge in like what
constitutes harassment because there are
harassment laws okay and some could
argue like he tweeted at me three times
I've told the stop and he kept doing it
and maybe you'll see more of that okay
I'm good I don't care don't harass
people even if even if it is minor then
what to figure out where that line is
well I didn't I mean sending someone
death threats is is pretty significant
but that's versus versus going on every
single being a reply guy and just like
saying mean things all the time it's
just like okay you can just block them
you just right bet you know exem from
your page so there was a big there was a
guy in Canada who after he got blocked
kept tweeting at him because you can and
then he got I think he won but he got
arrested for harassment because of this
okay either way look man if
if we say that legal speech is protected
then the past 10 years will be erased
all of a sudden you'll see every
conservatives start saying exactly what
they think what they want you'll all
you'll have people who have been banned
coming back you know maybe not
necessarily coming back because they
might say oh our bands are you know in
effect or whatever but this would be
massive there's another there's another
potential for victory and that's
decentralization which we're seeing now
with the wind Network okay The Donald
dot win sceptic this is really this is
really hilarious right you start with
with Reddit okay reddit was basically a
a parent forum with a bunch of smaller
forums and then because reddit has
become totalitarian like the the justice
served subreddit announced you can no
longer post videos of people of color
who are committing crimes yeah so
choosing they're they're pushing the
specific narrative that fits their cause
only and that's it and that's that is
not free speech
well they don't believe in free speech I
know you can make white people look bad
well so here's it happened the Donald
OTT win declared independence you know
good for them oh and they created their
own website mm-hmm that's a clone of
Reddit and it's actually growing in
rankings and now something a surprise
something something magical happened
what several other subreddits declared
independence and are now part of an
independent decentralized da twin
Network do that so people are actually
becoming aware of this
clickbait moistures know the culture
lays forums are the anti s.a.w forums
it's not a new discovery for these
people these are the four bearers of the
fight right but they're they're
separating themselves because they're
realizing that this they're they're it's
cancerous they're cutting the cancer out
off of their their body basically
declaring independence sure and so this
might restore some of the balance
outside of 230 reform if these
communities that are anti SJW that are
conservative moderate intellectual dark
web say we are going to have our
subreddit be a functioning independent
website no one can change the moderators
and if people don't like it they can
just leave no one will have the power to
ban them or can
their speech I love that so sounds
alright dave rubin has been working on
locals calm which we've talked about a
little bit privately for those aren't
familiar the general idea is it's your
own website it's a functioning social
media network with an independently
connected network between other channels
but it's your website on your server no
one can touch it it's pretty cool
no one's gonna ban you no one can ban
you it's your your website someone could
go to Dave and be like Dave you know
this this person on locals said a
naughty word and they'll be alike I mean
that's their server we're gonna do about
it yeah and so that decentralization is
a is a large solution of this the
problem is like with parlor parlor came
out and immediately the leftist media
attacked it as far-right extremist Nazi
etcetera you know so though this time
though they're still doing it however
because of high-profile conservatives it
didn't stick and it didn't work all that
much that's true when parlor first came
out I'm not entirely sure what happened
goes a while ago but I think Apple tried
banning it from the app store
oh wow and then I think it was Trump jr.
somebody intervened and was like why and
then it like got reinstated or whatever
so now they're trying to run a smear
campaign saying all the worst possible
things about it and it's because the
left controls all the cultural
institutions yeah so one of the biggest
problems the right has is they're not
cool actually I actually talked to this
musician about this and he was pointing
out that one of the things that works
really well for what we're doing on this
show is that we're like stereotypically
cool guys skateboarding
you know music playing you know it's
really cool types you know what's really
cool
standing for up for what you believe
that's saluting the American flag and
following all the rules s that's cool
and you know it's it's crazy because
there's a lot of people on the left that
that do we exactly that and that's why
they're they're so powerful right now we
need more people standing up for what's
right because they think they think
they're right over there and they stand
up for themselves and they stand up and
they they proudly do you want to hear
some into the air what they believe you
want anything really funny of course
there is a punk rock song from a band
called propoganda okay and it's called
stick the effing flag up your GD
a you son of a B Wow
and the song if they're Canadian I guess
so but I remember listen it song when I
was a kid because my my older brother
showed it to me and the song is
basically like this dude is being told
to salute the flag conform and don't you
dare speak out against it otherwise
you'll be destroyed
yeah and so then he says well if this
country is so GD free and then I can
burn your effing flag you know whenever
I whenever I damn well please yeah the
interesting thing about it Ryoga is that
there's today I wasn't listening the
song earlier you know Iceland ton of
punk rock and I'm like this makes no
sense there that right now there is no
you you you can burn the flag and that's
it and and nobody nobody you don't get
cancelled for it I don't know I don't
like that at all because you burn
specific flags and that's hate speech
but you burn the American flag that's
that's not hate that's just you saying
that it's you know I'm gonna deal speech
I am going to rewrite the lyrics to that
song oh yeah yep cool and I'm gonna say
the same thing if this country is so
free I can burn your flag whichever one
yeah but but anyway I listen to this
song and he basically talks about one of
the lines is romanticized murder for
morale okay talking about the war tie a
yellow ribbon around the oak tree my my
friend and gee Wally that's swell like
the idea is like back then when they
wrote this song it was you supported
your country they would go to war you do
as you're told and if you spoke up
against it it was like oh you got like
like someone someone brought this up
that if in in in the early 2000s you
mentioned that the reason we were under
attack by terrorists was because of it
was retaliation for our actions in the
Middle East and ca-- you would be banned
cancelled kicked off shows Bill Maher
had his show politically incorrect right
cancelled for you know and so yeah so
the political correctness existed the
funny thing now is is on the left it's
all leftist cultural you know censorship
like it always exists in some form yeah
the funny thing is oh listen listen to
this song I'm like it like somatically
fits more with our fight against the
left than it does anything to do with
challenging war interesting
but for one big reason Donald Trump is
trying to pull our troops out of
Afghanistan and they are stopping him
they're smearing him they're attacking
him they're saying no we must
investigate this rush of collision stuff
and I'm like if I was gonna run an
anti-war song right now it would be like
yay Donald Trump not f Donald Trump
right it would be like bring our troops
home Donald Trump is the only one doing
it what right well I mean it's Rand Paul
don't get me wrong okay Thomas Massie
there's very few people that are there
actually like anti-war and it's the
craziest thing to see Republicans
cheering right now being like yay we're
ending the wars I'm like wow yeah Wow
but but but you know you're listened to
you know what's really weird about it
tell me Tim the Bad Religion wrote a pro
alt-right song really yep hmm weird
another guy never really listened to Bad
Religion so I don't really know that
music I used to listen to Bad Religion
all the time they claimed that this song
was against the alt-right but if you
listen to it you're like oh good this
this is not against the all rights it's
it's telling people to like it's it's
it's promoting them there's like some
lines in the song now when you say all
right like what are you talk white
nationalism oka by people who believe
there should be a country just for you
know the kid white for the white race or
whatever aren't right the kids are all
trite okay that's the name of the song
and like the choruses everybody needs
somebody join the party and become
alright today oh my god it's like that's
that's fairly Pro maybe maybe their goal
was to be like ironic okay but right now
you know that the the argument for the
left is that ironic humor is the same as
yeah so they basically made an ironic
Nazi song where they're pro-nazi and
here's what I think now if some people
swing for the fences and not everyone
gets a home run it's a good point I
think the issue that the issue though is
as much as the left look man punk rock
is not left-wing anymore if you wrote a
song where you were like f the war F you
know bring the troops back half American
imperialism you're not talking about the
left they they're they're pro war not
all of them
you have the progressive anti-war people
they tend to agree with us on our
positions about free speech yeah people
like Glenn Greenwald for instance
they get their free speech battle as the
issue of Israel and Palestine but they
absolutely like it's funny scene Glenn
Greenwald constantly defend Donald Trump
because of the Russia gate lies in the
media lies and the pro war stuff I know
it's funny so if I was gonna write a
song today and it was punk rock and
really crazy I could write this whole
anti-war song condemning the politicians
and saying you know F your cause F your
demands F your votes and and the war
bring the troops back and it would end
with like and that's why Donald Trump
needs to win and it's like they're
voting for the Republican suit-wearing
Pro America flag-waving guy is now the
anti-war move that's true he's the only
one there other Democrats and maybe
maybe I just need to research each
individual Democrat but it was a
bipartisan effort for the most part to
stop Trump from pulling our troops out
and of Syria to they attack him for it
they want the one all the people that
have been in charging in government for
a long time don't want things to change
he's the anti-establishment president he
wasn't supposed to win man I know that's
why they don't like him and so I think
they're gonna change that's why I like
him the more I look into it I I don't
care I'm saying it like whatever that's
if you got your news from only the New
York Times you would your your image of
Donald Trump would be like a winged
demon snarling with like fangs yeah and
if you actually watch Trump it's
actually more just like a 70 something
year old lewd young guy I mean I
actually watch all of his speeches you
know it's not that hard
pay attention I really think I think
that Donald Trump's speeches are like
the ultimate way to get a feel for what
the media is actually thinking and
that's what people are doing you got to
do is watch his speech yep and you can
listen to what the media says about it
and he'll change it said this and then
they were like oh no he actually said
that's like no no I know that's not true
yeah but now I know that's crazy yeah I
know I tell people like it people love
to bash him like this whole Facebook
thing like I I'm keep talking about it
but you know I'm on facebook I'm openly
saying these the same stuff I'm not
changing at all and people are coming at
me like oh
blah blah and I just asked each and
every single one of them have you ever
listened to any of his speeches the
answer is always no and I just say go
listen to his speeches before you even
talk to me about him I don't need to
listen to a racist I know what he said
yep I know I love the the do you see
this the video of the reporter asked a
woman you know oh you know who are you
voting for she's like well I don't I
don't have to tell you well who you vote
for and she are you voting for Trump
she's and the reporters like yep and
she's like well you're white
supremacists then oh that's Caitlyn
Bennett oh yeah it was a great video and
and she goes alright well so are you
voted for Biden yeah oh well then you're
your pedophile well well so it's
actually better it was a good logical
twist yeah so she's like you're voting
for Trump and Ben and Kaitlyn's like yes
and she goes well then you're a white
supremacist and she goes how can you say
that what proof do you have who does you
support Trump and then she goes so you
have no evidence it's like it's not my
job to to to do that for you yeah she
goes okay are you voting for Biden yes
she goes okay then you're a pedophile
and she goes what that's not sure he's
like you like touching little girls yeah
that's and that's it oh man that that
cracked me up man like listen the
Baffler logic that is the logic of the
left there's no logic of the left that
that's my point right so here's here's
what moderates and and traditional
liberal people like you know like like
me or whatever we're gonna call it the
average person who opposes this
mentality this ideology doesn't
understand they have no logical pathways
you know it's literally just like I'm
like mashed potatoes in there in their
head they they have duct-taped together
somehow a system that can pull a
nautical current but you can't map it
you try to use a Socratic method you try
to make these points they don't get it
well you think about it the human brain
doesn't fully you know complete you know
complete growing until you're 24 you
know you're gonna sit still so so we
have no idea really the the effects of
having an iPad in front of you altering
your brainwaves from I mean to
three-year-olds are on iPads they have a
phone in their entire life we know that
you know the blue lights keep your awake
your brain thinks that it's still
daytime so you don't go to sleep the
same it's like we have no idea so
not only is it mashed potatoes but it's
it's not a brain that we are used to
it's not we can't we can't compare
ourselves up we're like a different
breed of humans almost because we're
we're part of computers there we are the
new head works
they are the new AI I almost you know
cyborgs yeah there they are the bored
their brains are developing with this
digital internet technology are the Borg
Wow I that's crazy there's you know the
story they are they are they not is that
that's pretty nuts to think about feels
like I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you guys in
the chat to correct me but my general
understanding of the Borg in Star Trek
was that they were regular a regular
civilization like humans that started
integrating medical technology that
expanded to a point where it
synchronized them and then created a
hive mind over time I think so they used
to be regular people and then over time
I don't know I don't know if it started
with humans because they assimilated all
sorts of different races over over time
not humans like the Borg was a humanoid
like race riot then became this and then
started assimilating all the other you
know races yeah I'm not sure if you guys
know the Borg is right don't know they
know not to talking about it you will be
assimilated with simulated resistance is
futile not if I can help it right resist
man I love the Borg episodes I know some
of the best Picard lines yep well seven
of nine yeah let's Deep Space nine yeah
no no Voyager to avoid your oh I messed
up oh that's it I'm officially out
there's there's always jokes we made
about a Trekkie fan demand and who knows
more than someone else so I will defer
to you I clearly know more than you you
can have that trophy did you hear that
everybody
he admitted it I'm gonna take this I'm
gonna take this w and run that's right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you